my question relates somewhat to Sonny's
question is how do you measure the
success of an investment investment
you've made an organization how it
ranges from our education to healthcare
and if it doesn't have concrete or
immediate returns how do you know that
you've made an impact I think that's a
challenge with which I've been
struggling my entire life and I think I
will continue to struggle and I balance
between statistics regression analysis
quantitative metrics and the pulling at
heartstrings how can I say no when
someone pulls at my heart stream when
there's an immediate person I'm looking
at her in the face and I know I might be
able to help her and so doing that might
be able to help all of us that is beyond
statistics
it's the one-on-one but without
measuring the things where there can be
a measurement I think it's ignoring
reality and it's leads to tremendous
inefficiency certain I find certain
things better tend toward measurement
certain things are more experimental and
emotional and it's sometimes cyclical
what's your opinion in the work that
you've been doing for it's been muscle
or with the impact that we've we can
make as an individual I find can't be
measured exactly when it's such a short
time span if I would do work in Ecuador
that I've done over the spring break you
know that you can't make a huge
difference in the time that you're there
but the emotional aspect of it I think
overpowers good so my question is the
difference that you're making there for
the people who are on the ground and is
or is the difference the difference it's
making in you I believe it's a
combination of both their response kind
of fosters what difference it makes in
me and how I change as a result of
helping
I think that's great and what I found
some of the relationships I built when I
was your age those relationships
continue I'm still in touch with those
people so even as what seems like a
short time if they feel comfortable
calling me and I feel comfortable being
in touch with them and now it's easier
and easier to penetrate so much more of
the world those little steps it's not
the act in my mind is not the finite
action about many days or weeks it's
building a network of trust